gymshark will soon be bigger than nike
with its recent seven million dollar
investment into gymshark hq we got
excited in a matter of minutes you will
be able to recreate your very own
gymshark hq just like ben francis turned
nothing into over one billion dollars
you'll turn nothing into a blacked out
building what took ben's team of
architects years to model i'm going to
show you in a matter of minutes so
there's no messing around today let's
turn around to these two screens and get
started okay so to start off we're going
to take a couple screenshots of where
gymshark hq is located i've located it
on google maps i'm going to simply take
a quick screenshot
of that building including the scale bar
so we can scale it properly coming in to
3d satellite terrain i'm going to also
take
a couple screenshots of the actual
building so i know what's happening on
the outside now we're going to start by
dragging the first original screenshot
into archicad 25 so we can start with
the base and understand how big that
building is by pressing control plus k
we can rescale this picture accordingly
so we scale up this bar here to 20
meters and now we have the size of our
actual building control z opens it up to
movement let's just move it out of that
space we have our building perfectly in
the middle of our screen click on a wall
tool select external we're not going to
go into any details today of archicad
we're just going to smash out the model
of this building so you can do the same
very very quickly following through
we're literally just going to copy the
shape of this building all the way
around now that we have the outline of
building we can delete the map behind us
and we can click on our 3d model to
understand how far we've come already we
can then again command d drag that over
command t and increase the scale and
size to be proportionally correct so in
this case that's 10 meters we can
understand by tapping m to get our
measuring tool out that this building is
about 10 and a half meters in the center
and about 12 and a half meters in the
middle coming back into 3d we'll see
those walls have skyrocketed all the way
up so to create a nice sprung roof we're
going to use the shell tool i'm going to
select one end the second end drag all
the way up we come back in take a look
at the gymshark hq you'll see it's this
beautiful glass black building now
compared to what it was before so we
have a portico at the front glass
everywhere and just a black building for
the rest so relatively simple selecting
command t
let's repaint all of our walls to black
straight away let's go ivory black okay
sorted we have the start again do the
same thing for the roof replace that
with ivory black now we have that roof
reconnected by splitting that roof in
half cutting away the excess four or
nine so we click the tap four nine away
re come into this 3d command t dropping
this back down let's go to four meters
we'll simply drag and drop a nice big
slab on top of that ctrl d bring that up
and making sure that it's black as well
now we have the start of our gymshark
building all we have to do now is
introduce all of our glass elements what
we see is four identical windows across
the front face of this building so we're
talking about six meters wide three
meters high in total we could start by
utilizing window 25 so we're going to
change that to six meters wide three and
a half meters tall which straight away
gives us the window we are looking for
four horizontal one vertical will give
us the look that we are after in this
situation so clicking okay coming back
to our building itself we can introduce
one window here a second window here now
if we come into 3d we'll see we've
already created the first two of our
windows going back to the original
gymshark photo they are on the ground
measure again we can see they're five
meters in the air so 3d window click on
these two windows once command d drag to
the bottom command d command once more
five two drags it all the way up we have
our gym shark buildings and our gym
shark windows happening very very
quickly i'm gonna replicate the same
process on the rest of these walls and
come back to you really quick i have
recreated all the windows on the side
introduced one large window at the back
and also extended one huge pane of glass
at the front here whilst also
introducing the entry to the gymshark hq
as you can see here the final finishing
touches to make this a perfect quick
remodeling of the gymshark hq is the
massive iconic gymshark logo that we see
on the glass here so if we want to
recreate that we have to find a gymshark
logo like we have right here so let's
save that to our downloads come to our
archicad and simply just go to our
ground floor dragging and dropping that
logo directly in i'm going to start by
using the morph tool to redraw this
shape exactly as it is so if we quickly
trace around
the gymshark logo by clicking around
every tooth and then simply expanding
out on the curved sections of the
gymshark logo within a matter of five
seconds we've recreated that gymshark
logo which is absolutely massive so
command t
starting from the bottom assuming the
top dragging down six meters let's
simply drag that roughly close to the
front of our building come into 3d
you'll see that we have the morph logo
in 3d so if we select both the logo
command t
let's make that out a solid 100
millimeters downwards on both sides so
100 millimeters there and again on the
eye 100 millimeters we have a logo that
we can work with if we click on both
sides click on the front of our building
command e we're going to use each
individual plane to help us reorientate
our logo exactly the way we want it so
command e 90 degrees using the top of
this command e again 90 degrees command
d allows us to move it place it exactly
where we want and drag it into position
i still think that's excessively big
command t picking one side picking
another and rescaling i think we need to
scale that to about four meters so that
should be perfectly sized now if we drag
and drop that roughly to the middle just
double check the color it is a nice
white glow command t
override surface and let's paint that a
titanium white with a black outline on
all sides clicking ok
and there we have it we have our
gymshark hq building completed in a
matter of minutes anyway that's all for
me today guys thank you so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed it if you
did hit the like button hit the
subscribe button and as always i'll see
you next monday